i love that after that i wanted to hang
out with him every day where are you
going today mars [__] it i'm coming
where you going parole i would go to
parole with him i met his parole officer
i [__] was a shadow
i wanted to learn how to do that [__]
what the [__] did he just do
so again i mean i would go to work with
him this whole summer and you know what
it wasn't just about [__] around with
this guy this guy was by the book he
made me
his favorite words in spanish would
justify your existence [__]
you're coming up there but you got to
work i would have to iron
go to the store get bottles of
blackberry brandy for all the bookies up
there
i would have to [__] work and walk in
a rough neighborhood i mean my dad
didn't take me up there wasn't cake
kids and [__] sand these were
buildings that were
you [__] played and broke down
buildings in those days you get cut
[__] there was no tetanus shot
tetanus shot
these little young kids walking around
with bottled water where's 90 degrees we
drank bottled water
what [__] water in the bronx didn't
have that [__] [__] then this was a
[__] crazy
neighbor yeah at the end of the day i
went to manhattan and you know
everything was good and we got bull foot
rubs
but in the daytime we worked in a [__]
up neighborhood
my father abba juan was also he had a
different problem
he was what's called in cuba abba kwah
abba khwa is a very [__]
weird religion it's a man religion it's
about men they're all longshoremen and
they believe in manhood
things that a lot of things i don't
agree with him like he always carried a
straight razor
the reason why i carried that was his
weapon of choice because he would slice
your ass
that's the mark of a that's their thing
they go to humiliate you you're not a
man
they slice your ass that was his bag i
didn't know about this [__]
he had this weird tattoo over zeroes
with an x
and that's the abacua religion it's not
santeria where they kill chickens
these guys are just men i'll tell you
how much men they are
they don't need [__]
they don't eat [__]
was where that came from that thing
about if you suck [__] you might suck a
dick it was these guys
they don't suck [__] that's just how it
is there's no listerine in their [__]
bathroom they do not
they don't eat that [__] monkey
number two he can't be in a room with a
gay man
like if right now if there was a gay guy
in here get me out
get me out i can't be in the room with
them that was their [__] deficiency
like they just they were men
that's you know that you couldn't talk
to them weird you could you gotta laugh
very respectful but if the saint
of abercross is san lazaro it's a guy
with two dogs
do you ever see that [__] guy on
wheelchair on crutches and he's got
sores
and there's a dog licking him that's
saint lazarus so they honor dogs
so on top of all this not eating [__]
or whatever this [__] honored
dogs
like michael vick when michael vick went
to jail he couldn't go to a lot of
federal penitentiaries do you know why
because the abacus the abacus would have
killed him in a [__] heartbeat they
would have sliced his ass
they were you think i'm [__] kidding
you look at the michael vicks thing he
couldn't go to a lot of federal
penitentiaries because a lot of abacuas
where they're from cuba
those are the guys that came in the 79s
those crazy [__] scarface
remember when he asked them what's that
on your hand
a pitchfork you're an assassin that's
the abba claws
they're [__] nuts okay so one day we
go to this bronx thing we finish up he
goes come on let's drive back home and
me and him are just driving home alone
he had an electric 225 one of those big
[__] cadillac's big
let me tell you something he had bullet
holes in there nothing you could shoot a
you could shoot a bazooka
and an electric 225 and just go ding
ding that's it these were metal [__]
detroit heavy cars right
the lights popped open like the green
horn this is a [__] car
who i remembered it was when he got
arrested one time they got confiscated
he was [__] pissed that's my [__]
car [__] so we're driving this
electric 225 and we're at a light
think of laurel canyon and ventura at 4
30 that little intersection
4 30 is pretty busy we're at this light
and all of a sudden
i see two dogs stuck running bass
none of you [__] have ever seen
two dogs stuck that only happens in the
bronx or where puerto ricans are around
you know what two dogs stuckman's
they were [__] okay and somebody said
something to him
and they got scared so the male dog
turns his leg around
and he runs with a female dog you
[__] never seen that don't
laugh
you're looking at me like joey what the
[__] yeah that's not
they don't even have that discovery
channel because it don't happen no more
okay you never see two dogs [__] so
the one the male dog will run and the
females gotta run backwards
because the dick gets swollen and the
thing pulls the monkey
it's like a [__] anchor it's like an
anchor when the dick goes in it goes
and it opens up and it so we're sitting
there and we see the [__] male dog
run by
stuck to the females she's running
backwards i'm like what the [__] is that
right
and also you see the guy chasing him
with a stick right some [__] guy like
running down the street hey
come back in he's trying to hit the dog
so he catches the two dogs and he's
hitting the mail
with the stick and people are beeping
it's not like today with you oh iphone
9-1-1 you're on your own [__] there was
no
cell phone in the car you're on your
[__] own all right so everybody
like two people were beeping i'm sitting
there playing with my [__] gi joe
like i have a [__] momo
and i see my stepdad hit the button he
goes hey stop hitting that dog
and the guy turns and goes mind your
[__] business this [__] in
that day of time traffic
popped that [__] car into park and
got out of there and when the guy turned
around it was too late
it was too late juan was on him like a
bad [__] suit
just started punching this [__]
in the stomach punching him bam bam bam
he was a fighter this guy knew bam i'm
sitting the car again like clapping
that's my [__] dad [__]
look at that [__] go give him a
cape [__]
give him a tape that's a superhero right
there [__]
oh my god damn and he got back in the
car like nothing what's up nothing let's
go
guys on the floor bleeding and [__] from
his head he pet the dog he took him
apart
and [__] he didn't get you think the
cops were gonna cut he didn't give a
[__] about cops
this guy had no idea he had no fear i
would look at him and go how the [__]
aren't you scared like
you know how some people smoke it he
would smoke cigarettes and throw him on
a [__]
thing on fire aren't you scared of the
gas tank or not no i don't give a [__]
he just didn't care he had no fear for
that [__] and little by little i started
knowing him now
he had this white dude he used to hang
out with he was locked up with big owl
big eye was a white dude that had long
hair but every time i see him had blood
on him you know those people they got
some type of blood on their hand or
something
big hour was a crazy [__] so
going to the second grade big eye would
come over a lot at night and they would
talk late night because he wasn't still
allowed to go in jersey
so i would go to bed and i'd get up to
pee at like three and big allen him
would be at the table
now juan did not do drugs juan did not
drink
if you drank or did drugs he thought you
were weak
that no [__] question that you can go
to him well i smoked marijuana
because i have sleep apnea and i have
anxiety he's like you're a [__]
[__] that's what it is that's why you
smoke marijuana
because you're a [__] weak [__]
that's that's how he thought he didn't
like drinking him my mother owned the
bar he would not
step foot in that [__] ball he hated
everything to do with that [__] bar
he hated
all any of that [__] he hated he would
stay home at night smoke his little
cigarettes drink coffee
and read [__] novellas like
love stories this is this guy with
[__] little glasses on he read love
stories at night
every night i wake up and big out
because my mother would always wake me
up at three when she come home from the
bar with a cuban sandwich
so i would wake up and there was always
be drama with a big album he always had
blood on his shirt or blood on his hand
one night i get up and i see [__] ow
naked in my living room
ball's ass naked with juan with a candle
with alcohol and i see juan burning his
[__] arm
right rubbing this thing on his arm and
burning it
and i just my mom's like who could go
back to sleep they're doing something i
didn't know what the [__] they were
doing
the next day i asked him before school i
go what the [__] was going on last night
he goes big out shot some guy and i had
to take the gunpowder off his arm
so they strip you down they throw away
the clothes and then they [__]
take all the gun powders if they do that
test on you you don't have any gunpowder
and when i'm [__]
seven i seen this [__] so another night
i wake up and al's there again he's like
come here i'm gonna teach you how to do
this
i'm like teach me to do what take the
gunpowder off you might need to know
about this one day and [__]
are you [__] saying you got a bunch
of candles out they made this thing with
[__] alcohol and something else
and they put it on their hands and they
got to burn it off and [__] so every
time i would shoot somebody me and juan
would [__]
one night he came home stabbed like a
[__] out
i mean every [__] week al came i
think he was doing some dirty work or
something like that this guy did
something
this guy wasn't [__] normal you know
i figured that out the night after he
got stabbed in the neck and he's there
drinking
eating a cuban steak with blood coming
out of his neck this steak is delicious
like ow go to the hospital i can't go to
the hospital dog there waiting on me
he was one of those type of dudes so i'm
like
what the [__] kind of people is his
mother what kind of people are these
what kind of people i didn't he was my
hero guys he was teaching me let me tell
you how good this guy was with numbers
by the time i was at the end of first
grade i knew my times table
12 times 12 all that [__] backwards and
forwards in spanish
and [__] english because he
stressed numbers every time i walk in
they go four times eight
six times two you know you always
[__] confuse me with that
three times three take away four and i'm
giving you five apples
you know he was one of those dudes so i
was always sharp but mad my math was
[__] sharp i mean this guy was just
finally got off parole and he was
allowed to go to jersey
finally and he would go to my mom's bar
just in the daytime like at six to help
her out
once the [__] drunk started coming in
he gotta go come on let's go
i can't be around these [__] retards
i couldn't believe it i go what do you
mean bro these people put my
i can't be around them they drive me
[__] nuts he'd go home early
do his push-ups this guy was in shape
you know
it's [__] crazy but let's get down